what if i told you that brazilian
counter-strike's next breakout success
the next coldzera the dude who is slated
to bring
mibr back to the promised land
couldn't actually compete in any valve
sponsored events
why because he was convicted of cheating
when he was 13.
this is a test of the emergency dimitri
oh hey i almost missed you if you're
seeing this clip
it's because dimitri really [ __ ] up
and didn't promote
the score esports awards streaming live
this friday december 11th
on our youtube and twitch channels live
at 5 p.m
listen 2020 has been a strange one for
esports
but it still gave us plenty of
incredible plays and great moments that
we'll remember forever
so come hang out with us in the chat as
we hand out some hardware
and celebrate the greatness of esports
in 2020.
by the way dimitri i was really hard at
work at something having to film this
has disrupted my schedule so
i got something for you too bud
okay so if you're at all plugged into
the world of cs go then you've probably
noticed that a certain
hashtag has been trending for the past
few weeks
from casters to competitors to community
figures to
fellow convicts it seems as if everyone
in counter-strike
is saying the same thing free vsm
free vsm man so who the hell is this guy
and
why is the cs community so taken with it
well
he's venesius vsm moreira the 20 year
old brazilian who spent the past
month or so single-handedly bringing
mibr
back from the dead get it because their
coach
dead was found guilty of cheating and
they lost all their major points as a
result
i think it's funny anyway so this should
be good news right
for those who don't know mibr have been
down on their luck for quite some time
and about three months ago they hit rock
bottom and decided to clean
house as a result hell-bent on
revitalizing their good name
mibr replaced their legends of
yesteryear fallen
taco and fur with a whole new host of
names
some old some new the crazy thing is
that on the back of vsm's ridiculous
play making
they're performing way above expectation
and now he's going to get aggressed upon
but they give him a chance to clutch
oh he gets nowhere lined up and now it's
just half health for olaf
he's run out from tunnel and it gets
shut down
mi br aren't stopping can't be
stopped vsm continuously putting up
these clutch plays
brazil should be over the moon
but they're not because vsm
is vac band now for those who didn't
watch our don't at me on crims
vac stands for valve anti-cheat the
official anti-cheat that's done
pretty much nothing to stop hackers of
various sorts from
dominating fps's such as counter-strike
for the better part of two
decades vac is without a shadow of a
doubt
the worst anti-cheat in the known
universe mostly because of how old
it and cs's engine actually are for
context
there are 1.6 cheats that theoretically
should still work and go
they'd get caught like immediately but
as far as i know
they'd work it's also unintrusive which
means
unlike face-its escas and valorance
anti-cheats
it doesn't dig itself into every nook
and cranny of your computer
this means that the only cheats that vac
is capable of reliably detecting
are the so-called free cheats the ones
you get when you're a
stupid 13 year old who types csgo
wallhacks into google and downloads the
first thing you see
now i can only assume that those are the
kinds of cheats that vsm was using when
he ate an
automatic vac ban back in 2013.
why because he actually was
13. after bursting onto the scene in
2017
at the age of 19 vsm was immediately
declared to be his region's next hot
commodity
comparisons were quickly drawn between
him and coldzera
and in 2018 he signed to daytona gaming
and that's when he really blew up
the issue is that come november esl
discovered something
a vac ban on an account that had
allegedly belonged to vsm when he was
but a preteen
now esl chose not to punish him for it
presumably because of how
young he'd been when he committed the
offense valve on the other hand
did what they always do to anyone who
they deem to be guilty of cheating
ban them from competing at any and all
valve sponsored events including majors
needless to say valve takes vac bans
very seriously if determined to be legit
these bans are permanent and
non-negotiable
this ain't no two-year esl ban that
is for life if you get slapped with one
and it's sound
your career is legitimately over valve
will not even entertain
an excuse now to be fair if you're a 24
year old who's contracted to a
world-class roster a lifetime ban
while admittedly harsh isn't that
unreasonable it's safe to say you should
have known better
take cali for instance the french opera
who ate a vac ban in 2014
just weeks before he was supposed to
play at a major
then again if you're someone like yampi
whose account got backed back in 2015
when as he alleges he wasn't even
playing on it
this whole lifetime ban with no appeal
thing
doesn't feel especially fair or fruitful
needless to say
valve's black and white approach to
disciplining cheaters
has definitely sparked some debate over
the years everyone knows the story of
the i buy power boys whose fabled match
fixing scandal
rocked north american counter-strike to
its very core
for years the community pleaded with
valve to unban
brax and his poor repentant compatriots
all to no avail things got so bad that
they had to switch to valorent
like i just
poor bastards so what makes vsm's case
different from all the other ones that
valve has refused to budge on well
assuming that the ban is legit and to my
knowledge vsm has never denied owning
the account in question
he wouldn't have just been a
non-professional at the time of his
offense
he would have been a literal child
unfortunately for vsm
i don't think valve cares what age he
was if history is
any indication of what's to come the
very fact that vsm had
any association with that account
whatsoever is enough to do him in
for good yampi tried to claim that his
account was banned at a time when he
wasn't even playing on it
he took them to a [ __ ] court over it
and still
they wouldn't listen valve has never
ever budged on this kind of thing and
it's hard to imagine why they would now
remember if they all of a sudden make an
exception for vsm
that would open up the floodgates for
all of the other cheaters they've
blacklisted over the years
if vsm walks free why not yampy why not
brax or the rest of the eye by power
guys
where does valve draw the line and while
i may not agree with valve's absurdly
stubborn approach
cases such as vsms do offer a very
valuable lesson for kids who are still
coming up
if you are at all serious about esports
please don't ever cheat
ever even if it's just for fun it can
and will catch up with you anyway it
sucks to say but
i don't think the ban is going to be
reversed anytime soon should it be
i think so will it given what we know
about valve's ethics policies
it seems extremely unlikely still
here's to hoping that by some miracle
valve does decide to unban him
vsm is an absolute animal and deserves
to represent his region at the absolute
highest level of play
so for what it's worth hashtag free vsm
it's it's so fun it's so crazy what
needs to be considered
like competitive for a map in cs go like
anubis is a map in cs and it's been in
like the
the scrimmage rotation unranked in cs
like you can play it in the game for
for like forever and like they still
haven't taken mirage out of the pool or
inferno out of the pool and just put in
anubis
everybody whines like everybody wants as
soon as you take a map that's out of the
pool that's like
a real cold map it's like people just go
crazy like
people in cs have severe stockholm
syndrome and they really don't like
change
they if you change any they've become so
used to the fact that like
that they're that valve that daddy
doesn't love them that if daddy comes
along and shows them like the little bit
of love they're just like no
i don't want it like no that's bad
that's stupid
stupid and it's frustrating as hell dude
coming from other esports like being
familiar with how other esports run it
is
immensely frustrating